هل ستزور الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
ايران نهايه نوفمبر كما كان مقررا المدير
العام للهيئه الامميه رفايل جروسي ليس
متاكدا
عقد هذا الاجتماع
لذا هناك شكوك وامنوا ان يوضحها الايراني
محمد اسلامي ان الزياره حاليا غير مطروحه
على جدول الاعمال المسؤول الايراني شكك في
فائده الزياره اذا وافق مجلس محافظ
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه على مشروع
قرار اقتراحته الولايات المتحده وثلاثه
دول اوروبيه يوم الثلاثاء مشروع يدين
طهران لعدم تعاونها مع الهيئه الامميه
بحسبك روسي الزياره المفترضه من المقرر ان
تتطرق لمعالجه قضيه ثلاث منشات اكتشفت
فيها اثار يورانيوم لم تصرح ايران عنها
قضيه مثلت نقطه تباين اساسيه خلال مباحثات
احياء الاتفاق النووي المبرم عام 2015